it's a new year which means I'm doing
what I do every year seeing if there is
a new Might and Magic RPG or a Heroes of
Might & Magic game hell at this point
I'd take a sequel to Dark Messiah for
the uninitiated Might & Magic it's a
classic high fantasy franchise that had
its heyday in the 90s the Heroes of
Might & Magic series is a staple of how
to execute strategic turn-based combat
and city building while the mainline
series are dense party based W RPGs in
sprawling memorable worlds times have
changed though and while there actually
is a new Might and Magic game this year
it happens to fall into the order of
battle of genre Might and Magic chess
royale injects the universe and
creatures of the franchise into the
strategy genre where you compete in a
number of one-on-one matches that lead
to knockout rounds and eventually result
in a soul winner the Might and Magic
franchise persisting is a wonderful
thing but trying to enter the order
battle of genre in its current state
probably isn't a good move for Ubisoft
for a bunch of reasons and for patient
fans hoping for a big mainline game it's
not great news for them either
but I'm getting ahead of myself so let's
back up a bit and explain what on earth
an Autobot Allah is the order babblers
onra only kicked off early last year
with the release of dirty order chess a
community created mod for dota 2 where
you manage resources to create a
garrison of complimentary units and
arrange them in strategic ways to defeat
your opponents in one-on-one matches the
catch is you can only control the setup
and the rest of the battle executes
automatically thus the name Auto
battler valve hastily developed the auto
chess inspired dota under Lords which
was quickly joined by offerings from
many other major studios dominating the
free-to-play market League of Legends
develop a riot release team fight
tactics and Blizzard revealed hafsteinn
battlegrounds both of which work the
auto battle a format into their existing
worlds in the unique ways on top of that
the original team behind dirt auto chess
now have their own game on the epic
store called Auto chess long-winded
explanation short there are a lot of
places you can play an order battler
right now martin magic chest Royale is
only in an early access state right
now so it's understandable that
balancing is currently unrefined
but the main thing Ubisoft is touting as
its defining feature simply isn't good
in its current state said feature is a
far quicker gameplay loop than others in
the genre but it currently feels frantic
particularly in later rounds and there
isn't enough room to apply real strategy
while the early game is slow late-game
there isn't enough time before the
action kicks off to rearrange your
troops inspect your spell's sort your
synergies and gain the competitive
advantage through logic in some
circumstances I knew exactly what I
wanted to do but the late-game time
constraint in addition to some
unreliable hit boxes left the wrong
troops on the board when the battle
commenced on top of that the order
populating data which plays out during a
battle is delivered too quickly and as a
result it's hard to review your tactics
and reshuffle to design a more effective
garrison winning logic does in some part
rely on choosing and creating creatures
with aligned synergies proper board
placement and use of spells
unfortunately some synergy buffs are far
more useful than others and the more you
play the more you realize there are
characters and play styles you
absolutely have to gravitate toward if
you want to do well outside of the games
quality in its current state then move
into the order battle of genre feels
like a fall from grace for the franchise
the Might and Magic name used to stand
for innovation and imagination it led
the charge as an example of how to
execute a brilliant turn-based strategy
game in the early 90s and its main line
series Illustrated compelling fantasy
worlds with deep body based W RPG
systems despite the relative infancy of
the order battle of genre ubisoft faces
extraordinarily stiff competition
against the ultra polished offerings by
valve riot and blizzard which dominate
the genre and have the development
expertise and invested audiences to
continue to do so by that same token
fans with nostalgia for the Myton Magic
franchise are attached to the complexity
of the fantasy worlds and the sprawling
systems built beneath them bringing the
franchise to the genre of the moment is
a risky move when that genre is
inundated by franchises with huge player
bases that already show an interest in
strategic competitive multiplayer games
ie not the audience of the Might and
Magic franchise don't get me wrong it is
a delight to see Might and Magic suite
of magical creatures feature in a new
game
and I'm happy to say the Battle Royale
element of chess Royale is the first
I've managed to score back-to-back wins
in but this isn't the meaty game that
patient Might and Magic fans have been
hoping for chess really is enjoyable
enough but it's a shallow experience in
its current state valve riot and
blizzards offerings all have that quirks
that play with the higher levels of
strategy such as dota under Lords use of
heroes or the drafting system in
teamfight tactics where you pick new
champions based on the order of your
successes so far a process that elevates
poorer performing players in the case of
Might and Magic order chests there is
little to differentiate itself in a
positive way that matches the two faster
for effective strategy certain synergies
feel overpowered and some spells are
downright game breaking in chest rails
defense there is a joy in getting into a
multiplayer game on the ground floor and
mastering it alongside everyone else
especially as other Auto battlers on the
market are so closely tied to their
games of origin that is to say you're
gonna have an easier time quickly
plotting good garrison combos in
battlegrounds if you already have a
knowledge of hearthstone chess where al
does share elements of this but in a
less useful way longtime Might & Magic
players will know to keep arches and
magic users toward the backline but so
will anyone who knows about basic army
strategy this isn't the first time you'd
be soft have tested the Might and Magic
franchise with an up-and-coming genre of
the moment and more than anything it
seems to cement the end of the mainline
RPG and strategy series in favor of
mobile and free-to-play avenues which is
a sad reality for fans with so much
nostalgia for the franchise back in 2019
the Ubisoft Might and Magic creative
director oh and lebreton told acid cave
net for a large company like Ubisoft
turn-based strategy titles like heroes
and now too costly to produce because of
the scope expectations and our overhead
costs and too limited in their sale
potential Martin magic cherry L might
have been an opportunity for the
franchise to be revitalized but it will
undoubtedly disappoint fans who are
holding out for a bigger game that
reminded them of the ones they loved in
the past let me know if the drawer of
Red Dragons and harpies is enough for
you to want to try this one out
if you digit Oh in the auto battle of
genre or if like me you're still holding
out hope that this isn't the end of the
line for the Might and Magic franchises
main line entries